Why am i attracted to trying to solve
simple problems. Well I think one reason
is that I've always been attracted to
carnival games and you know I like
looking at these things like trying to
throw a ring around a coke bottle or
walk a tightrope or you know bowl
over glasses with the ball and you know
just thinking about how can you do this
these kind of very simple looking things
anyone can understand what you're
supposed to do but then it's very hard
to do it and so I've always just liked
the kind of the mental challenge of
doing things like that I also like
simple problems because I think that
they reveal hidden depths in mathematics
if there's some problem that's been
around for a long time and no one's able
to solve it it means that somehow
there's a kind of completely new idea
that you need to solve it so there's
this great appeal of trying to come up
with some new idea that no one's ever
seen before
a third thing is that I like to do
experiments and these kind of simple
looking problems like the one on my
screen here seeing is called Langton
Zandt this is a famous unsolved problem
in maybe in complex systems or in
dynamics so I like to I like to make
computer programs and I like to run
experiments and kind of gather data and
see if I can notice patterns and these
simple problems are kind of you know
grist for the mill I can just just code
them up pretty quickly and I can do it
um another thing I like about simple
problems is I'm sort of lazy about
learning new stuff and a very impatient
person so I like to be able to just hear
the problem and just kind of jump right
in and start thinking about it I think
of these kind of simple problems is sort
of like Lords of giant mansions and and
they're kind of they're willing to sort
of let you into the ante room they'll
kind of you can kind of walk around the
lobby and they might even kind of let
you up on the first floor so they
started accessible in a certain sense
and then there's always a hope that
there's like some back door into the
mansion you can go all the way up